the last time we were together you were
growing a garden how is the garden
well the garden is garbage um
it was great last year and then
i got
victimized by a pack of raccoons
there were six raccoons because i have
my cameras you know and i was like what
is going on because i would go outside
in the morning to water my garden and
there would just be things plants all
over the place like holes dirt
everywhere i was like what happened in
here it looked like like a human being
came and like dug everything out i
looked at my cameras and it was six
huge raccoons flying across the lawn
going to the beds and just like they
didn't even eat the vegetables that was
the worst part they just like ransacked
it for pleasure
well i don't know what their endgame is
and i'm still trying to figure it out
they just like threw away all these
beautiful organic hand grown vegetables
and they just didn't eat them and i'm
assuming they buried some
you know valuables or something in there
well you tell those raccoons that they
better stay away from your garden or i'm
gonna come and kick their you-know-whats
well
i will and i'm sure they will listen to
me but i am sprouting sprouts right now
i am doing seedlings i am not giving up
i will prevail don't give up
don't give up and
maybe a little fencing
oh you think i haven't thought of
fencing
in the beds around the edges and i
covered it in like sheets and like
bird
wires they ripped it all out they're
very strong
now i would love to ask you which is so
crazy this is the third time um before
we get to doll face this is the third
time we've done the show together and i
never talked to you about doing sex in
the city
oh my god
i love you in sex in the city
i love you in that episode so much what
was it like give me fly on the wall what
was that like well it was amazing first
of all i was
i think 13 maybe 14 uh i was oh god look
at the look on your face
look at the look on your face
i was a fetus i
didn't know what the show was my mom and
i took a cab from penn station to my
audition i was like this is a weird show
it has the word sex in it i don't know
whatever and when it was time for the
show to air
we didn't have cable so my mom got cable
and all my like little girl friends came
over with their moms to watch the show
and if you oh
remember that this is one of the most
messed up episodes of sexism
because my mom like ran to turn it off
like it was so to everyone's mom was
like
it was crazy but at the time i just
thought it was cool and doing some tv
show that i had never heard of and i got
to wear pretty outfits and have my hair
done and everyone was really nice to me
and
so sassy yes
and michael patrick king was there uh
who i later worked for who created two
broke girls
i mean
that is an origin story for sure um okay
tell me about doll face this is the
second season of this show what is it
about doll faith
that speaks to you or that you get to do
differently
well you know i am a real sucker for
like
feel good stuff i've done you know a lot
of fun amazing things but there's just
something about the warmth and coziness
of this show and
um the cast is just the most incredible
group of women and i love them so much
brenda song is
one of my best friends in the world and
that chemistry really translates i mean
you can't fake that kind of thing so
that's really fun for people to watch
and um
yeah season one left off with my
character jules um
ruining someone's wedding
and then uh exposing brenda song's
character madison's boyfriend as being
the husband of my
boss so i blew everything up essentially
and this season begins with me going
into the office for the first time after
the pandemic assuming that i'm going to
be fired but instead i get promoted
so
well if anybody tries to mess with your
wedding you call me and i will meet them
in a dark alley at a very late hour and
i will take them down i will give them
the raccoon treatment
so much i was thinking of having a
raccoon officiate so we'll see how that
goes
thank you so much kat i love you so much
season two of doll face is available now
on hulu and we
will be right back
[Music]